T
EAST, THE OTHER A STE ISNDCOONS
THE OTHER IS E ABORT
A REPORT OUT ABOUT
CALIRNERNOOM
TO PICK A GOVERNORIDA AND IWIL
LOOK.
IT'S INENCE D
ME.'LK WHAT'S GOIN
BOOKS, MAKING IT HARDER TO IYOUS
RESTRICTING SPEECHN
CLASSROOMS, EVENDOCTORS.
I LLU NGN TO JTH IN CIFE WE
STILED.
I THINK IT'S  US IN
CALIFORNIA LINE THAT'S PROBABLY.
DOING HERE?
OSOCIAL, OU FLODA
TAKING THT.M NO DS Y
ENGAGING
IS TO?
>> DeSANTIHACH SHOUL
WAY THAT THIS IS B
VERYSIVE TROLL ODeSA I $100,OF
YEAH. IT,CAME
OUT AFTER E LEAKED DRAFT OF
THE RODEN POLITICO AND
T FIGH
RTICULS
IN THE CULTURETHE QUESTION IS,
NEND T
SOSEMONEWHS MO
YOU KNOW, HE'SN
NO COMPETITIVE IO
THE FALL
DE THIS RECALL.
ONE OF HISDVE HE'SBULLWORTH  KIO
FROM HIM ONTHCIAL WHE HR
STATES WERE HIGHER ES.
HERY BE THIS VOICE ES IR REPUBL.
ANSTUC POINT, HE TOLD ISAA
THE RIGHT TOINE THE TERMS OF
THE SUCCESS OF THE  DE THE
S O 'RE WINNINS THATMING TO
CHANGE.
YOU HAVE TTA
SO, ISE WAYS?
MONTHS, A LOT OF DEMOCRATIBA
FIGHTING FIRGOING MORE
AGGRESSIVEGA
OR U AS LE
LOT OF VOTERS ARASKINGY T PRESI
T THE MINISTRATION OUT THERE MO?
AND THAT
ICANS IN
>> I MEAN, HE SAID -- I THINK II
FO BUT THAT THAWHAPPENS FAIRLYC.
IF EVEIND TONG US, BUT  TS D
POCS
HE HAS T
TH. S TO DO SOMETHG
HE'S FILLING VACUUMMPTAHE'S
FILLING VAUMI HEAR THIS FROM TH
G THOS WS A
FEELIN
AGGRESSIVE ENOUGH.
THEYN FIGHTING THESE
- SPECLY
2021, ALL THE REPUBL
TALKING ABOUT ALL THISON
SEUSSTHIS MOCKING.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, OH, TH WORKIN.
GEUST
AWA
CULTUR
FILLING THIS V
HE'S OBVIOUSLY SAVEN'TO GAVIN N
MOTIVATIONS HERE'STYEA
RON DeSANTIS HAS
BUILT THIS INCREDIBLE NATIONBRAR
HE'S SEEN THIS G G